in what way do you mean I'm pretty
predict who with it how can I decide who
with it
ah well so it can certainly make people
available to you at with as much
percentage for example we can it can use
your information to try and find
somebody who is a better for you based
on what you're looking for that says
actually people who are the best looking
don't necessarily come off as the most
popular and actually having people think
that you're ugly can work to your
advantage which sounds incredibly
counterintuitive right and so there's a
mathematician and called Christian
rudder who set up a dating website and
on that dating website you used to be
able to rate how attractive people were
between one and five slightly cruel
section of the website unfortunately um
but you can compare that to how many
messages people would receive and he
found that it's actually the people who
divide opinion the most who end up doing
the best not the people who are just you
know classic girl or guy next door so by
the divided you means the people that
some would find very attractive and
somewhat like we think whereas it looks
like a dog's dinner yeah
so that will be the best yeah that's the
base of the people who do the best but
it's kind of interesting because when
people choose a profile picture to go on
online dating they try and pick the
picture where they had to know like the
love the day they had the loveliest hair
or their skin like the nicest or they
try and make themselves and you know
look the most attractive and minimize
any flaws that they have but actually
it's the opposite of the type of thing
that you should do instead you should
play up to whatever it is that makes you
different because really quirky things
end up doing really well and so in fact
actually your earring there we go
perfect that would be a good say yeah
say people with tattoos do really well
on online dating and people with
something people piercings people with
you know anything that's sort of quirky
and a bit different about you and makes
you stand out and you used to have any
older tail as well you really well there
we go perfect but the reason is is that
people who are messaging you are
thinking about their own chance
as well so if they think that you're
really beautiful but that everybody else
in the world is going to find you
attractive they imagine that there's
loads of competition and and you know
just what's the point in them getting
involved
should-should won't be I don't know if I
mean I I feel well is this enough I
don't know but it should won't be
proactive oh yeah yeah so this is this
is a really nice example actually of a
mathematical framework of some equations
that you can use to prove something that
then actually ends up making sense back
in the real world so if you can imagine
that you've got a group of single people
in a party now you can sort of split
that party down the middle and say okay
perhaps some people are going to be
proactive and approach you know the
object of their desire and other people
perhaps is going to stand back and wait
for their choice of suitor and in that
framework you can prove mathematically
that the people who are proactive will
always always always end up much better
off than the people who sit back so even
risking humiliating rejection and all of
the drama that goes with that if you
approach people in a proactive and go
out and get what you want you will end
up with the best person who'll have you
or as if you sit back and wait for
people to come to you you'll end up with
the least bad person who approaches you
so you would be able to mathematically
predict that now you will get an
applause
and the reason is because burglars get
to know the layout of your house they
get to know where you keep your
valuables they get to know the escape
routes and so on